So there are all these different ways
you can think about what recognition is.
And one of the two main distinctions
we've already talked about, but
it pays to point it out again,
is this difference between
single instance labeling, okay?
So here's a picture of a car.
And we say, you know, that's John's car.
Okay, and so we want to be able to find
that particular thing versus we'd like
to be able to find all of these
things and say, okay, those are cars.
For the most part, we're going to
be worrying about this problem,
the generic categorization problem,
okay?
So object categorization
described in a variety of ways.
This is a slide from Kristin and Barrett
Leibe, and that I changed a little bit.
Generically it's kind of like this.
Given some number of training examples,
training images of a category, recognize
some a-priori unknown instances of that
category and assign the correct label.
Now you notice that I put down
small in parentheses, you know,
right here it says small.
These days not a lot of work
is done on the small number?
That is that, typically we
have lots of large examples.
And there's a question about
how method's that go from
taking large data could
then use small data?
To me that's a slightly more
interesting problem, but
we'll leave the small as being
sort of optional at this point.
But the basic idea is that I give
you a set of these things and
some sort of labels, and you want to
give me back the correct label.
All right.
So one of the things we have to do,
before we can even proceed is,
we have to agree on a set of labels.
And there's this fundamental
problem that a single object
doesn't have a unique label.
So here we have somebody's dog,
apparently named Fido,
I don't know if anybody names
their dogs Fido anymore.
So you can say well this is Fido or
you could say this is a German shepherd.
You could say this is a dog.
You could say, doesn't say, say it's
a mammal, you could say it's an animal.
You could say it's a living thing
although a living being is probably I
don't know out there.
But it, it is these things, right, so
there's this question is what categories
are best for visual identification or
which ones do we agree upon.